House Intelligence Committee members are
arguing over president Trump's claim
that former President Obama ordered
surveillance of Trump tower before the
election committee chairman Devin Nunez
is accused by the ranking Democrat of
trying to divert attention from the
president's claim that he was wiretap by
his predecessor congressman Adam Schiff
says Nunez is trying to confuse the
issue that effort to defend the
indefensible has led us down this
terrible rabbit hole and threatens the
integrity of the only investigation
that's authorized in the house president
Trump's former campaign manager Paul
Manafort has volunteered to be
interviewed by lawmakers investigating
what intelligence agencies say was
Russian interference in the election for
more on the investigation we're joined
by Matthew Rosen Rosenberg he reports on
intelligence I'm national security for
the New York Times Matthew good morning
how are you so Paul Manafort Carter page
Roger stone all Trump advisers have
volunteered to testify The Times reports
that all three are also under
investigation
what is that volunteer testimony tell
you I mean I think for manna for
especially he says he didn't do anything
wrong this is getting out ahead of it
trying to say look I'll come in and kind
of get a storyline going but it doesn't
take us away from this giant bombshell
it was dropped this week that look the
White House is under investing an
espionage investigation right now which
is just astounding and then you've got
the the chairman of the House
Intelligence can be going out and
talking about these obscure technical
details or names being masked or
unmasked and it held its reports it just
is running off to the White House to
report to them when they're under
investigation it all looks really bad so
as you said the FBI director confirmed
that the Trump campaign is under
investigation for possibly colluding
with Russia for the elections but now
eight days later since that announcement
they're headed to the hill why you know
I do think that they're just trying to
get out ahead of it and these guys you
know they're they're distance from the
Trump campaign is kind of growing with
every day a matter of what was pushed
out in August stone was sort of this
weird side character Carter page who
knows what his relationship was I mean
he says he was tied to it the Trump
people said we don't know who he is you
know
it is really confusing so I think they
think they can just get out of this get
out of the way here there's a cloud of
confusion over all of these proceedings
right let's talk you bring up Devin
Nunez who has had a difficult in there's
been bipartisan criticism of his choice
to go to the White House with
information relating to the Trump Russia
investigation the New York Times today
this morning calls Nunez a human shield
for the Trump administration does this
House Intelligence Committee still have
credibility
I don't not much I mean with anybody
outside extremely partisan Republican
circles no it doesn't the Democrats are
already calling for independent
investigations there it's not gonna
happen it will there be a special
prosecutor we don't know yet you know
but those calls are getting louder you
know if that was known as this goal to
enter this torture plus special
prosecutor he did a fantastic job but I
don't think that's what he's trying to
do and and running off to the White
House like that and then kind of go into
the core technical minutiae of how Intel
does report are supposed to work we've
got these huge big issues the Espionage
investigation and the fact that you know
you're now dragging the director of the
FBI back in for closed testimony and
Nunez seems to have issued a little bit
of a Mia culpa on that decision to go to
Trump first right but that's like you
know the old thing you always do yeah
you kind of asked for forgiveness after
the fact right you know everybody's
worked has done that with their boss
before Matt Rosenberg thank you thanks a
lot guys